la figura de arriba muestra una cuerda
con un extremo atado a un oscilador y el
otro extremo atado a un bloque
la cuerda pasa sobre una polea sin masa
que gira con una fricción insignificante
cuatro cuerdas a b c yd están juntas
como se muestra en el diagrama de abajo
esta es la vista superior de los
osciladores las cuerdas y las poleas
cada oscilador está ajustado para hacer
vibrar la cuerda
con su frecuencia fundamental efe la
distancia entre cada oscilador y polea
es la misma y la denominamos l así que
la longitud entre el oscilador y la
polea es l y es la misma y la masa m de
cada bloque es la misma así que es la
masa lo que está proporcionando la
atención en la cuerda sin embargo la
frecuencia fundamental de cada cuerda es
diferente vamos a pensar qué es esto de
la frecuencia fundamental y luego vamos
a pensar en qué es lo que las hace
diferentes una forma de pensar acerca de
la frecuencia fundamental es que es la
frecuencia más baja que va a producir
una onda estacionaria en la cuerda es
aquella frecuencia que produce una onda
estacionaria que luce más o menos así
es la onda estacionaria en donde la
cuerda es la mitad de la longitud de
onda de hecho hay dos formas de pensar
en esto es aquella frecuencia más baja
que puede producir una onda estacionaria
o es la frecuencia con la que se produce
la onda estacionaria con mayor longitud
de onda la cuerda en su frecuencia
fundamental va a estar vibrando entre
estas dos posiciones podemos ver aquí
que la longitud de onda es el doble de
la longitud de la cuerda si quieren ver
mejor esto si yo continúo dibujando la
onda aquí tendré que seguir dibujando
otra longitud de la cuerda para regresar
al mismo punto de la onda y completar
una longitud de onda si no vengan al
dibujo aquí sube la onda baja y luego
vamos por abajo de regreso se está
reflejando a partir de este extremo de
acá como mencionamos antes lo que está
haciendo la masa es esencialmente
proporcionar la atención la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa sobre esta masa
proporciona la atención en ésta
y el oscilador está vibrando a la
frecuencia correcta para producir la
frecuencia más baja que puede producir
esta onda estacionaria ahora respondamos
a las preguntas
aquí tenemos cuatro de estas
configuraciones y todas tienen
frecuencias fundamentales diferentes la
ecuación de la velocidad de una onda en
una cuerda es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de la tensión de la cuerda dividida
entre la masa de la cuerda dividida
entre la longitud de la cuerda donde efe
subte es la atención de la cuerda y m /
l es la masa por unidad de longitud
densidad de masa lineal de la cuerda
todo esto tiene sentido porque si
aumenta la atención va a aumentar la
velocidad puede pensar en la atención
como que tanto se están jalando entre sí
los átomos de la cuerda por lo que si
hay una mayor tensión se van a jalar más
entre ellos conforme la onda pase a
través de la cuerda y también tiene
sentido que mientras mayor sea la masa
si todo lo demás se mantiene igual la
velocidad va a disminuir ya que pueden
ver a la masa como una medida de inercia
qué tan difícil es acelerar algo así que
si en la cuerda hay más masa por unidad
de longitud de hecho vamos a señalarlo
porque es de interés si hay más masa por
unidad de longitud tiene sentido que
para cierta cantidad de cuerda sea más
difícil acelerar la adelante y atrás al
hacerla liberar por lo que esta parte
será inversa a la velocidad no es
proporcionalmente inversa porque aquí
tenemos esta raíz cuadrada pero
definitivamente aumenta la densidad de
masa lineal
tendremos una menor velocidad pero si
aumenta la atención tendremos una mayor
velocidad espero que esto tenga sentido
para ustedes nos preguntan cuál es la
diferencia entre las cuatro cuerdas
mostradas arriba que resulta de tener
frecuencias fundamentales diferentes
explica cómo llegaste a tu respuesta una
estudiante grafica la frecuencia como
función de el inverso de la densidad de
masa lineal la gráfica será lineal
explica cómo llegaste a tu respuesta
respondamos a cada uno de los incisos
cuál es la diferencia entre las cuatro
cuerdas mostradas arriba que resulta de
tener frecuencias fundamentales
diferentes
bueno recordemos lo que sabemos sobre
ondas la velocidad de una onda b es
igual a la frecuencia multiplicada por
la longitud de la onda dividimos ambos
lados entre lambda y podemos decir que
la frecuencia de una onda es igual a su
velocidad entre su longitud de onda si
hablamos de la frecuencia fundamental
va a ser igual a la velocidad de la onda
dividida entre la longitud de onda que
es el doble de la longitud de nuestra
cuerda 2 l y si vemos la expresión que
nos dan para la velocidad de la onda en
la cuerda esto será igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la tensión de la cuerda
entre la densidad de masa lineal todo
esto dividido entre la longitud de onda
que es 2 l todas las cuerdas tienen
frecuencias fundamentales diferentes
pero veamos qué es lo que cambia dentro
de esta fórmula todas tienen la misma
tensión como lo sé porque lo que causa
la atención son las masas que cuelgan de
las poleas el peso de esas masas por lo
que esto será igual para todas las
cuerdas además todas tienen la misma
longitud por lo que la única forma de
que podamos tener frecuencias
fundamentales diferentes
que tengamos masas diferentes
para responder a la pregunta las cuerdas
deben tener densidades de masa lineales
diferentes puesto que todas tienen la
misma longitud entonces todas deben
tener masas diferentes vamos a
escribirlo
las cuerdas
las cuerdas deben tener
deben tener masas diferentes
masas diferentes
y diferentes densidades
d
más a línea ya que todas las demás
ya que todas las demás variables
qué determina
que determinan a la frecuencia
fundamental a la frecuencia fundamental
son iguales son iguales
ahora resolvamos el inciso b una
estudiante grafica la frecuencia como
función del inverso de la densidad de
masa lineal la gráfica será lineal
explica cómo llegaste a tu respuesta
vamos a subrayar esto frecuencia como
función de el inverso de la densidad de
masa lineal podemos escribir la
frecuencia como una función de la
densidad de masa lineal podemos
reescribir esta expresión aunque mejor
la dejamos así 1 entre 2 l por la raíz
cuadrada de f subte o la tensión entre
la densidad de masa lineal
podemos decir que esto es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de la fuerza de tensión
entre 2 por l y pongo esto separado para
dejarlo en función de la densidad de
masa lineal por lo que podemos suponer
que todo esto es constante y esto lo
multiplicó por raíz cuadrada de 1 entre
la densidad de masa lineal si vamos a
graficar la frecuencia como una función
de esto la gráfica definitivamente no
será lineal primero tengo aquí el
recíproco de esto y luego le saco la
raíz cuadrada vamos a escribirlo
la gráfica de
la gráfica de f de m / l
no será lineal no será lineal
pues involucra e involucra raíz cuadrada
y
el recíproco
y el recíproco de la variable
de la variable de m / l
ahora resolvamos el inciso c
la frecuencia del oscilador conectado a
la cuerda d se cambia de tal manera que
la cuerda ahora vibra en su segunda
armónica en la vista lateral de la
cuerda de mostrada abajo marca los
puntos en la cuerda que tienen la
velocidad vertical promedio más alta una
forma de pensar en la frecuencia
fundamental es en la primera armónica
cuando la cuerda está como la mostré
anteriormente es la frecuencia más baja
que genera una onda estacionaria o la
que produce a la onda estacionaria más
grande o con mayor longitud de onda si
es nuestra primera armónica la parte de
la cuerda que se mueve más será el
centro de la misma pero en la segunda
armónica es la siguiente frecuencia más
alta que produce una onda estacionaria y
en esta situación en lugar de tener una
longitud de onda del doble de la
longitud de la cuerda tendrá una
longitud de onda igual a la de la
longitud de la cuerda por lo que ahora
se verá así
va a vibrar entre esto y esto de aquí
cuando vemos a esta versión tenemos la
mitad de la longitud de onda de la
primera armónica o la longitud de onda
que es igual a l las partes que más se
mueven son esta y esta otra no las he
dibujado perfectamente bien una forma de
verlo es a un cuarto y a tres cuartos de
la longitud de la onda justo a la mitad
no se va a mover nada o será casi
imperceptible ya que es una onda
estacionaria estos son los puntos en
donde la cuerda se desplazará más en la
segunda armónica la segunda armónica es
la siguiente frecuencia más alta que
produce ondas estacionales